le président de la république a chaussé
ses crampons le temps d'une rencontre
sportive ce jeudi 14 octobre emmanuel
macron s'est déplacé à poissy pour jouer
un match du variétés club de france au
stade léo lagrange
le numéro 3 a joué milieu de terrain
défensif aux côtés de rudi garcia je
vous rappelle qu'en 2017 président macro
est venu avec son équipe de sécurité
faire un match contre le mans en équipe
de l'om et ça s'était bien passé le
président est quelqu'un qui lâche pas la
faire sur le terrain comme on dit et
avait l'air très content de jouer avec
nous donc quand tout le monde trouve son
plaisir dans un match ça fait une bonne
équipe c'est une porte de sortie par
rapport à son métier entre guillemets de
président de la république c'est la
première fois bien sûr qu'un président
de la république en activité et faire un
match de football sa part d'ailleurs de
mettre le maillot c'est pas commun et
c'est curieux de le voir là ça reste le
président de la république il ya du
respect quand même pour la fonction et
pour nous c'est une belle fête il ya des
grands noms et l'important c'est de les
avoir je pense que c'est formidable quoi
et parmi les grands noms participants à
la rencontre sonny anderson leur boulot
christian karembeu ou encore alain
giresse
un match deux équipes les joueurs du
variétés club de france ont fait face
aux soignants du centre hospitalier
intercommunal de poissy saint germain en
laye qui était heureux de jouer de faire
ce match et puis cette façon de le
récompenser de tout le travail que l'on
peut accomplir pendant sept durant cette
épidémie je pense ça continue aussi
également envoyé voilà donc c'est une
nouvelle belle après midi près de 1500
spectateurs étaient présents pour
encourager les deux équipes qui se
respectent
[Musique]
et ça joue bien on plus c'est dans une
bonne ambiance avec des des petits
retraités qui sont des banques qui reste
comme il dit une bonne ambiance et
franchement ça continue comme ça il se
débrouille se débrouillent tous un vrai
bon le président sa première fois que le
bois jeux aussi c'était mort c'est
plutôt mort à le voir et puis bon ça va
tu as des bruits sont plutôt les embouts
de brest victoire 6 1 pour le variétés
club de france un match caritatif jouets
au profit de la fondation des hôpitaux
présidée par brigitte macron présente
lors de l'événement un chèque de 50000
euros sera remis à l'hôpital de la mère
et l'enfant de kaboul